in my remarks today I will discuss the
current economic situation and outlook
before turning to monetary policy since
my appearance before this committee last
July the employment situation in the
United States has been improving along
many dimensions especially with an
improving labor market that we expect
inflation over the medium-term the next
two or three years to move up to our two
percent target I don't believe in
chaining that the Fed food chain itself
to any mechanical rule I did not believe
that in 1995 I do not believe it now and
I had the privilege to meet with
Professor Taylor right after he proposed
the Taylor rule in 1993 what we can do
is try to assure a generally strong
labor market where it's possible for
those who want to work to find jobs in a
reasonable amount of time we can't
determine the wages associated with
those jobs we're beginning to see
discussions on that these capital
charges are sufficiently large it's
causing those firms to think seriously
about whether or not they should spin
off some of their enterprises to reduce
their systemic footprint and frankly
that's exactly what we want to see the
Federal Reserve is independent I do not
discuss monetary policy or actions that
we are going to take with the secretary
or with the executive branch